Now we're going to analyze
a more complicated example
of drag forces, where we
have an object falling
in a gravitational
field with gravity.
We have a resistive force.
And this is an object in air.
And so our model will be
for the resistive force
that it's going to be
proportional to the velocity
squared.
Now to get its direction right,
opposing the motion, j hat.
So this will turn out to be
a more complicated analysis.
But first again, let's
think about the units
of our coefficient beta.
It has the units of force
divided by velocity squared.
So we write the units of
force, kilogram meters
per second squared,
and the units
of velocity squared, meter
squared per second squared.
And so we see that we have
units of kilogram per meter
for our coefficient beta.
Now, we'll apply as usual
Newton's second law,
F equals m a, to get
our equation of motion.
We're looking at
the j direction.
And our forces are
gravity minus the velocity
squared resistive drag force.
And that's equal to the
derivative of the velocity
dv/dt.
In this example, it's a
one dimensional motion.
So I'm dropping any mention
of y direction for simplicity.
Now we can rewrite
this equation as dv/dt.
Let's divide through by m is
g minus beta over m v square.
And this is a linear-- it's
a first order differential
equation, dv/dt.
It's a non-linear equation
because the velocity
term appears here as a square
and there's a constant term.
But we can still
apply our technique
of separation of variables.
And so when we write
this equation as dv/dt
we'll separate out dv's and
t's, so we have d d times
g minus beta over and m
v squared is equal to dt.
Now, I'm going to do two
things just to clean this up
for algebra a little bit later.
I'm going to multiply both
sides by a minus sign.
And I'm going to pull the g out.
So I have 1 minus beta
over m g v squared.
And on the other
side, I have minus dt.
And now I can get this
equation in the form
that I'd like to
integrate, which
is minus dv times 1 minus
beta over m g v squared equals
minus gdt.
Now, the trouble here is
this integral is a little bit
complicated.
So I'd like to make
a change of variable.
And my change of
variable will be
u equals the square root of beta
m g times v. And that implies
that du is beta m g dv.
And the limits, if we
start our object at rest,
so if u0 equals 0, then
because v0 equal 0,
that's our first limit.
Now we have to be a
little bit careful
because if we drop this
object at rest, initially
it will be moving very slowly.
And so our resistive model
doesn't actually apply.
However, we're going to
neglect that effect even
though if we were to do a
more complicated analysis,
we would have to change
our model as the object is
following, so it would
be a multi-stage motion.
First, at the beginning
with our only velocity
dependent resistant.
And then as it gets some initial
speed and it's going faster,
we change our model.
That's why the actual problem
can be quite complicated.
But we're just trying to
keep things simple here.
And then u of t is square
root of beta mg d of t.
And then with this change
of variable, my integration,
remember I have a dv, so I have
to multiply the left side by mg
over beta.
And I'm integrating with
a minus sign du times 1
minus u squared from 0 to
this final value u of t
And over here I'm just
integrating minus g dt.
Now again, for
simplicity, I'm going
to bring this term, the beta
over mg over to the other side.
So I'll use the magic
of our light board
by just erasing
that and bringing it
to the other side, which
makes my life a little easier.
And now, this interval
can be done by the method
of integration by parts.
It's a nice problem in calculus.
And you can verify for
yourself that the result
is one half natural
log of 1 plus u over 1
minus u evaluated at our limits.
And over here I have minus g
square root of beta over mg.
Now, once again, for a
little bit of simplicity,
I'm going to bring the 2
over to the other side.
And now, I evaluate my limits.
Now recall that when
you have a minus log,
we're flipping, because log
of b over a equals minus
log over ab, so when I
put out my limits in,
I have natural log of-- now
remember, what are our limits?
We have 1-- I'm flipping--
minus u is beta mg times v of t.
And I have the 1
plus beta mg v of t.
And that's equal to minus as
2g square root of beta mg.
Now, again, we'll use the
fact that e to log of x is x.
And so if I
exponentiate both sides,
I end up with 1 minus the square
root of beta mg d of t over 1
plus square root
of beta mg v of t
is equal to exponential
minus 2g beta mg times t.
And we'll just move that.
OK, now this is a
little bit of algebra.
I want to solve for v of t.
If I bring this
side over to there,
I'll just do that to make the
first step a little simpler
to see.
So we have 1 minus square
root of beta mg v of t
equals 1 plus square root
of beta over mg v of t times
e to the minus this factor
2g square root of beta mg t.
Now this is a lot of
stuff to carry around.
I'd like to introduce
a constant here,
tao, which I'm going to find
to be square root of mg beta 1
over 2g.
And so this whole term is going
to just be e to the minus tao.
It's a nice example for you to
work out that the units of tao
are the units of seconds.
And that's a little
exercise to work out.
Now, I just have to
collect my terms.
And what I'll do is
I'll collect the T
terms on the right and the terms
that don't have vt on the left.
So I have 1 minus e to
the minus t over tao
on the left is equal to 1
plus e to the minus t over tao
on the right times
beta mg v of t.
And so I get my
solution, v of t equals
the square root of mg
over beta times 1 minus
e to the minus t over tau over 1
plus e to the minus t over tao.
Well, it's not a
simple solution at all.
But let's examine when you
have a case like this-- again,
it would be a nice
exercise to graph this out.
But right now we're going
to consider the limit
as t goes to infinity.
And remember that
e minus t over t
goes to 0 when t
goes to infinity.
So we just have 1 over 1.
And what we get as
t goes to infinity
is the quantity mg over beta.
And this is what we call
the terminal velocity.
Now what does terminal
velocity mean?
Well, when object is falling
and there's a resistive force,
as the object falls
faster and faster,
the resistive force
gets greater and greater
until if we go back to Newton's
second law and look at it,
as v gets faster and
faster, eventually
these two terms are equal.
And when these two
terms are equal,
that's the statement that the
right-hand side has to be zero.
So what we mean by
terminal velocity
is it's the velocity is no
longer changing in time.
And then we can
immediately check our work
by going to Newton's
second law and see what
that case is if we set this
quantity equal to zero.
In other words, when
we set mg minus beta v
squared terminal equal to 0
we can solve for v terminal,
and we get a square root
of mg divided by beta.
And that agrees with
our lengthy calculation.
So we think we're
on the right track.